tyranny of the urgent gets in the way
can you make the technology work can you
get your first customers to pay you for
the product can you hire people and
people don't put forethought into the
culture that they're trying to build and
every company has a culture whether you
do it by design or not whether you
articulate the values or not and
especially in startups there's this
notion of building your tribe and a
tribe if you think of people who have a
common set of language a common set of
goals a common set of relationships that
could be a very powerful and motivating
force when you're trying to accomplish
something great but by the same token it
can become very insular and you can miss
what's happening outside of the
organization if you become too tribal on
the notion of tribal warfare and come
from when people become too isolated and
so if you can put the proper HR and
organisational dimensions in place where
it's not bureaucratic but it's the right
discipline and you scale it up as the
company becomes larger it makes things a
whole lot easier when you get to ten
fifty or hundreds of millions of dollars
in sales the notion of HR often gets
segmented off into benefits and vacation
policy and on-boarding and off-boarding
but really it's about people development
it's about helping people grow into the
job they're doing now and hopefully the
next two jobs they'll being able to do
later so if you think of HR as the
notion of the chief people officer in
many respects that's probably the most
important function in a company menhir
in Silicon Valley where it's axiomatic
that people are your most important
resources and your most important talent
are you giving them the tools to be
effective in their job are you giving
them the tools for their to grow of
their careers are you enabling
opportunities for them to accomplish all
the things that they want to do in this
company and even in future companies
because the great thing about doing
entrepreneurial endeavors whether it
works or not you might find that you're
building relationships that will come
back to you over and over and over again
in your career the best companies have
HR as an executive position at a seat at
the table the best companies are the
ones that note that the people asset are
what is
most important thing that you've got to
focus on in people development and
that's acutely more important as we move
to an increasingly knowledge-based
global workforce and so if you don't
have a person with a seat at the table
you will not get the best people on your
team if one believes in this notion that
diverse opinions actually can add to the
mix of creating a richer experience
sometimes people with HR experience who
might have been working for a decade or
two decades can bring pattern
recognition and can bring best practices
to an organization so you don't
necessarily have to reinvent the wheel
you can choose to do so where you want
to you can choose to put certain HR
policies in place that you think can
make your team's more effective by the
same token you can find people and there
are many of them out there who've worked
in bet companies that have taught best
practices for how to motivate people how
to grow people how to manage people how
to help people succeed who are
struggling and also how to coach people
out when it's not working so sometimes
there's some best practices of great
companies you know the larger firms I
worked for GE the organizational
development function was probably the
most powerful function inside of the
company because they realized that they
had to invest in their employees and
some of those best practices I've been
able to cop even some of our smallest
companies in our portfolio
you ask people ask them for feedback you
can pull them anonymously there are a
lot of tools and technologies that are
out there where people can give feedback
as to what's working and what's not
working sitting down and having regular
one-on-one sessions with your direct
reports what's working what's not
working doing it sometimes in an office
but sometimes going on off-site and
going to lunch in a more informal
setting
and I think baking that into the DNA the
organization where it just becomes part
of the natural conversation I think
young managers in particular are nervous
they're nervous because they've never
led before what if everyone figures out
that they're making it up as they go
along when all of us were managers for
the first time once upon a time and so
if you ask your teammates what are the
things they'd like to see changed and
improved that's where you can find out
what you need to do it's naturally not
hard it's not rocket science the most
important thing is to show up and do it
if you can build a culture of open
communication not avoiding hard issues
and not just where everybody gets a hug
but you can give feedback to each other
on what's working and what's not working
that's when it goes well but when you
don't have the ways the signals the
language about how to talk about values
how to talk about behavior that's
acceptable that's when it goes off
course a great example is in startups if
you have a teammate who's responsible
for a set of tasks and they're not
getting delivered on time or not to a
high enough quality how do you have that
conversation with people when it's a
collegial environment you're working
till 2:00 or 3:00 in the morning you
know maybe it's one of your co-founders
how do you say hey look you know you're
not getting the job done and that you're
letting the team down how do you have
that conversation in a way that is
professional it's directed but it's also
effective
it's one of the hardest things that
startups go through because if a team
comes together you start with all the
aspirations and hopes of trying to build
something new that no one's done before
and when one founder perhaps if this
skill set is not scaling as the company
grows or there's a personality conflict
how do you manage those situations
professionally but don't be afraid to
make a change
sometimes entrepreneurs are afraid that
they'll be judged incorrectly or they'll
be judged that they did not hire well or
choose well and so they'll keep doing
things over and over again that just
make things worse as opposed to actually
tearing off the band-aid every business
is different every business has its own
culture it's a function of the founders
it's a function of the leadership and
it's a function of the employees and I
think HR is kind of one facet of people
management more broadly it's about
organizational behavior and
organizational dynamics and so the
tactics of human resource management is
different than human resource
development and people development they
might be in the same function but if you
really look at your team as how when we
grow as an entrepreneurial organization
and we have that hyper going up into the
right are we gonna have the right team
in place that's going to be able to
scale with the organization and if not
what type of people are we gonna need at
that moment in time to bring in so you
want to always be thinking ahead about
you know how you're gonna grow and build
the organization and assume success such
that you can take advantage of the
opportunity when it's there